in Yemen they have become used to
burying their dead
there is something procedural almost
emotionless about all this
and yet it is different now because the
numbers these past few days have soared
they don't know for sure that it's
Corona
no one is testing but there is an
anticipation holes and space for many
more and there's a hopelessness - no one
here seems to be taking any precautions
this is a cemetery in the southern city
of Aden a place those in charge here
have now described as infested buried my
mother here the day before yesterday
this man says look now at how many
graves have appeared since this
graveyard will soon be full while more
bodies keep coming in
the roads out of Aden tell the story of
this country six years of civil war and
behind the destruction displacement
disease and famine the world's worst
humanitarian disaster it is a phrase
associated with Yemen for so long it no
longer seems to resonate and yet add now
to this corona a hundred and twenty
miles northwest of Aden inland is Tazz
this is a divided city split up between
all the warring factions at what they
call the hospital's isolation center
there are blood tests for those who turn
up unwell it is basic stuff
cholera dengue fever malaria all are
here all for as long as the war and with
spikes this time every year it's the
rainy season now and with that in a
country like this disease thrives this
is sana in the North Yemen's capital and
the Houthi rebel groups stronghold
at the city's main hospital dr. Hamden
battery shows us around in general we
haven't any sufficient solutions
seriously two-faced is a struggle just
only like that and how we can face this
struggle I don't know we haven't any
facilities we haven't a period totally
sufficient I see it sufficient that me
to face the struggle to face this
disaster we haven't just only have this
since this was filmed just a few weeks
ago it's now not possible to get into
the hospital the authorities in control
in the north won't allow access but it
is clear from those we've spoken to on
the ground that the intensive care unit
is now full and the mortality rate is
near a hundred percent Nikolas Busse
heads up the UN's refugee agency in
Yemen for him it's not just the
immediate problems but the knock-on as
squeeze donor countries pull their
funding to the media and therefore we
have to try to eyes our intervention we
will try to see what kind of program can
be saved but honestly within the few
weeks those programs will entirely stop
so we will be leaving 3.6 million
internally displaced and 280,000
refugees without any form of assistance
it's a life-and-death situation for them
and here they are filmed this month some
of the families who will soon have their
aid reduced or removed altogether in
Yemen and well beyond
Korona is impacting directly and
indirectly to still even among this
hopelessness or maybe because of it we
found remarkable ingenuity hello
everyone I am lighter than Russia a
medical engineer in a dusty room turning
what looks like junk into makeshift CPAP
machines those breathing devices that
have saved so many lives Global
and at a desk wires are bound together
to make thermometers the simple things
in my country symbol equipment symbol
device that we can like discover the
corona virus or something like that we
don't have I told you it's going to be a
disaster if Coronas interior man the
hope is that he's wrong but these images
and the figures behind them over just
the past week are grim mark stone Sky
News